il avait un visage ils ont désormais un
nom louis et marie thérèse plancoulaine
photographier en 1925 il vivait à
foucherolles à côté de courtenay
c'est leur nièce lucette sylar 90 ans
qui les a reconnu lors d'un rendez vous
chez sa coiffeuse elle m'a dit je
reconnais les mariés très exactement et
donc on a fini de la coiffer m'a appelée
une heure après l'heure après pour me
dire j'ai retrouvé une photo je crois
que c'est donc on s'est donné rendez
vous
elle nous a présenté donc la photo la
photo du mariage où il y avait plus
aucun doute gt turbo vraiment surprise
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment quand même
toujours heureux de voir leurs noirs qui
vote aussi longtemps prénom est décédé
comme en 1940 qu'avec guillaume ses
photos en verre ont été retrouvés
pendant des travaux
après une exposition au pôle culturel
elles sont affichées dans les commerces
de courtenay jusqu'au 1er mai ça sera
donné à un nom à des gens qui ont été
oubliés on a vraiment la sensation que
les gens avaient besoin de retrouver des
racines louis venait de la creuse
marie thérèse du cher alors
l'association courtenay en poésie se
tourner vers d'autres régions pour
continuer cette enquête on peut supposer
qu'à une grande majorité des courtines y
en a qui ont des origines autre que kurt
indian et c'est ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est grâce à cet avis de
recherche on va prouver à savoir
peut-être qu'il ya des gens qui venaient
plus du sud ou du nord de la france etc
et sens à notre chaîne locale on peut
pas aller plus loin que la sphère
territoriales bebert l'homme à l'enfant
la liseuse 16 personnages qui ont chacun
un surnom en attendant de découvrir leur
identité et leur histoire